it's time for drew's news and by the way
i have no idea what i'm saying because
what's in the prompter is a surprise
i don't even know the headlines that's
right that's why it's so fun
you put the drew in drew's news and
today it's all about you
you've been making headlines your whole
life from big newspaper profiles to rave
reviews
to even your advice for new year's
resolutions back in 1983.
you told people not to smoke not to
drink and to avoid
salt you also told them they should go
see e.t because quote that's good for
you
well et is still one of the biggest
movies of all time and you're still one
of our most beloved
stars let's take a look at a clip from
entertainment tonight
of you talking about making this iconic
film
i could act like myself the whole time
on that shoot because gertie sword was
like me
sometimes i cry and she does sometimes
cry
and it's a story about a whole family
and i love doing that movie
when you were in et or and even
afterwards a lot of what you talked
about is how crazy you were about steven
spielberg are you still such good
friends
yes we love each other i go over to his
house and
we we play games and we see each other a
lot and we're still
best friends yeah he um
yeah he's like the first person i knew
cared
he does care can you venture a guess
about who is about to join us right now
first person that cared about me yeah
please welcome the man behind countless
blockbusters
oscar golden globe and emmy
award-winning director who needs
no introduction steven spielberg
oh drew face i still care about you i've
always cared about you ever since that
first time
this little blonde hurricane walked into
an
audition in my office and took
uh us by storm and then soon took the
entire world by storm that was you then
and that is you today you know i think
one of the people that mean the most to
me
to be accountable
and a good person and have my you know
what together
is definitely you you're the person
yeah i want to can i tell you something
that you've taught me in life
you taught me that a parent
is supposed to make you feel bad when
you're not being good
and that you i i didn't understand that
um and i love my parents i really do
i wouldn't have the life i have today if
it wasn't for them so i wouldn't change
a single thing and there are so many
other attributes that they gave me
that other people couldn't but you
taught me
that how to be a parent and that
um if you're embarrassed about your
behavior around
a parent that that was a good thing
because they want the best for you
and you help me understand emotions that
i really wasn't privy to and i knew that
you cared and that's why i was
highly embarrassed when i wasn't being
good pun intended
and i always thought every time i was
doing something
good or right um i would always think
about
you know how you would think and feel
about it because i loved
making you proud i live to make you
proud
[Applause]
thank you and you've made me so proud so
consistently for
for i don't want to say so many decades
but come on let's face it it's been so
many decades
it's um it's going to be 41 it's 40
years
it's 40 years yeah you were six when you
made e.t
yeah and i'm turning 46 right now
so that's really works it does it's
perfectly seamless
stephen you first spotted drew she
auditioned for poltergeist
she did and you but you didn't she
didn't get that role but you saved her
for e.t
what do you remember it was 40 years ago
what do you remember about her though
well you have to remember that
poltergeist and e.t were made almost at
the same time poltergeist came first
and then i began shooting uh filming et
literally three weeks after our
production wrapped the last shot of
poltergeist that's how close
those films piggyback the productions
piggybacked and when i met drew for
poltergeist i immediately thought of her
for et which i was actively casting
as i was helping to also as a producer
i'll be helping to cast poltergeist
so um you know drew was really something
but when but her e.t interview was the
best
because when she walked into the office
she didn't want to talk about the movie
she didn't even
care what the film was about she wanted
to talk to me about her
punk band she was forming people eaters
none of it really existed but so so
we put a song in et purple people
leaders just in order to
please drew to to make that story kind
of have a full circle
but i if i could tell you one story when
we first started working with et
the you know the the beautiful you know
true to life heartfelt puppet um
i didn't want anybody to any of the kids
to really uh
break down that fourth wall and be able
to see how e.t runs
so all the wires came out of vt and went
through a wall where the operators
were behind the scenes working behind a
wall
and on the second or third day of
shooting drew had a secret she wanted to
share with me
and she walked over and took me by the
hand and she pulled me over to e.t and
she said
look at this and she pointed at the
wires and then she led me to the wall
and then she led me around the wall to
the four
e.t operators sitting around waiting for
action and she said
who invited them here what are they
doing here
and i just said well they're et's
friends and they're
really really helping e.t with his
english
and with his gestures and and making him
you know feel like he loves you which he
actually does and
and drew did not understand that there
was a connection
she absolutely never wanted to know that
anybody was making e.t
come to life except for e.t itself
tell me if this is right you guys that
it was actually drew at six years old
who came up with the line when she sees
e.t for the first time and she says i
don't like his feet
yeah she said that during rehearsal and
i said i said oh
drew can you remember to say that when
the cameras were rolling and she said
okay
and when we roll the cameras that was
the first thing she said you came up
with a lot of lines in the movie that
melissa matheson
had not come up with because part of the
authenticity of the movie is the
authenticity of
of uh uh you know mcnaughton and and and
henry thomas and dee wallace
uh and dee wallace who was like one of
the kids and that's why i cast her
because she
has such a childlike heart as well and
the only time i wanted to violate
all kids being in this movie was when
keys
the only adult steps into the picture
with all these coyotes
peter coyote and that was the only time
i wanted to violet like the rule
that he's a story of
by and four children and there's the
famous story and i think we have a
follow-up today courtesy of stephen that
when drew posed for playboy yeah
he sent you a quilt and it said cover up
yup because that's what parents do and
stephen then what happened
well then i sent her the playboy layout
and i had somebody from an artist come
over and do paper doll cut out clothes
which i
glued onto all of the partially exposed
photographs and sent the whole
thing back to drew now she's dressed yes
and and then about a week later drew
sent me something and i don't know if
you have it there but she sent me
an apology that was my response to the
playboy
it's being covered up yep yep and those
are still
like in one of your rooms in your house
yes
oh my god there it is
what she said on the picture was she
said the first one was
i'm sorry the second one was i've seen
the light
and the last thing frame is um
i'm on i'm on my way
you always uh just inspired me to be my
best
and then you held both of
my girls my olive and my frankie you
know all of right when she was born she
was so little
and she fell asleep on your chest
remember
and then you held frankie and you just
you know i come over to your house and
i'm just so glad
to be a part of your life and i i just
i love you and you've had an incredible
family
you know i was like a first young person
in your life
you were you you were my training wheels
for fatherhood drew
i'm so glad i'm so glad because you have
some
amazing characters loves you to pieces
as you know kate adores you and has all
these years
you've just made such an incredible
family
that i love so much and i love you and
kate
and i love when i'm at your home and
hanging out and it feels so comfortable
and yet it will never not feel
so special and i will always be grateful
because um there's no way i'd be sitting
here without you
ever i love you so much and thank you
and thank you and let me just say one
thing
uh just on a little more fatherly advice
but maybe more predictorial advice
i want you to direct more i loved whip
it so much
as you know you came to my office and
you sat in the screening room
and you showed me a rough cut of your
film for the first time and then i loved
um i loved our deal you know you know
best coast
uh the music video you made in 2000 and
i think it was nine or 2011
and i just think you're a gifted
director and i want to see you do that
more
i love you so much you make you continue
to make me so proud and i love you too
drew happy birthday
thank you steven thank you for my life
[Music]
you